welcome back to the official Joker movie
talk Channel I guess holy [ __ ] what it
seems like anyway so in another day in
the week that I'm gonna call the great
Joker in 2018 there is another bit of
information some more footage some
pictures to talk about in terms of
Joaquin Phoenix's Joker we have some
footage of Joker in a sub lane clowns
start beating people up and we have some
leaked pictures leaked pictures like
what are you talking about leaked
pictures leaked pictures don't look that
good leaks by who someone who wasn't
supposed to be on set who was on set
with a 35-millimeter camera who
perfectly framed up Joaquin Phoenix for
the shots leaked pictures usually look
like they're usually off-center
out-of-focus like a snap like they're
not supposed to be taking pictures but
they have the phone at the back we move
behind him like a click you know these
are like Entertainment Weekly spreads
but talking about the footage first yeah
he's in that Joker makeup that we saw
from that test footage screening trailer
not trailer promo thing in which I
personally was like I don't think that's
the final product of the Joker cuz I
didn't I was like I doesn't look like
the Joker maybe he's picking wings off
the flies but he's not there yet this
one mayhem is happening he might very
well be causing it he looks pretty fine
with it he's not even blinking he's not
even pausing he's just walking like yep
chaos I like it John Constantine's even
bailing I mean holy [ __ ] but really it's
the pictures that changed my perception
of him in this makeup it's a pretty
sinister looking dude it's not like he's
questioning it it's almost like a lot of
us people online or like I don't think
that's actually him as the Joker I think
that's to come later the studio's like
oh [ __ ] alright release these pictures
so they get the hint so essentially this
new Joker content this video these
pictures they've given us new
information new perspectives so I'm
adapting my perception accordingly
initially I saw that and I was like I
don't see the Joker I see someone who's
not the Joker yet someone who may become
the Joker and if I'm being honest is the
eye makeup it's the blue eye makeup a
little red eyebrows makes him look like
a clown not necessarily the Joker but a
clown at a birthday party but these new
pics make it look like he makes that
[ __ ] work and let's be honest if he
crushes it if he does the character
justice if he makes this new on-screen
representation of the Joker and makes it
his own I'm not gonna care I'm not gonna
be like ah but the eye makeup I didn't
like that I'll get over it I'll be fine
it really does come down to the
character of the actor's interpretation
the collaborative effort between him and
the director Todd Phillips but the
question of whether or not he is the
joke
that's the question for the philosophers
this is what I mean by that just to
clarify what I mean even though he looks
really [ __ ] sinister in these
pictures it's an origin story it's a
prequel story and here's what I mean by
if this movie's Joker is about a man
Arthur Fleck who puts on makeup and goes
and raises havoc as this Joker character
then goes home takes off his makeup and
goes to bed as Arthur flex I would say
this is the story of the man Arthur
Fleck playing the Joker in The
Metamorphosis stage to becoming what we
know is the Joker but as long as Arthur
Fleck the man is alive the Joker is not
fully there at a point when the makeup
is indistinguishable from the man at the
point when he wakes up as the Joker puts
his real face on that we call makeup
does all the [ __ ] up [ __ ] we know the
Joker to do and then goes to bed as the
Joker he is then the Joker that's the
way I see it anyway what face he is in
in this movie what face he is in during
the scenes in which these sinister ass
pictures are taken I don't know I won't
know until I say the movie for nothing
else all of this for the first time in a
very long time got me to flex my fan
trailer muscles in the early days of
YouTube I used to love making fan
trailers and I kind of did that I put it
on my Instagram I'll put a link below
check it out give us some love if you
want it was fun for me to make it's
literally two things I just layered
together that I felt fit all right so
this new Joker footage and these new
Joker pictures have you seen them what
do you think about them and did they
change your perception of it before were
you like I don't know and now you're
like okay cool whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]